I'm Dan Hynes and I'm here with Jamie
Wilson from Nintendo Australia Jamie
thanks for joining us no worries and we
are here with the new Nintendo 3ds so
we've got the 3ds regular size that's
right the name the new Union Tendo 3ds
XL so why don't we start with just the
um the normal one no what have we got
here on the outside we've got some new
face plates that's right so with the new
Nintendo 3ds comes equipped with cover
plates as we're calling them so they're
replaceable couple plates both the top
and the bottom that you'll actually be
able to take off and add new ones on to
you know mix up the design of your
console and customize it up a little bit
what are they going to be retailing for
I'm so in Australia and New Zealand bill
retail from 1795 they'll be available at
launch we've got 20 of the different
designs available straight up now the
first thing that you're probably going
to know this is you've got the
old-school like Super Nintendo button
design on the ABX and why yeah that's
right so the the ABXY buttons have
actually got the the color scheme from
the original Super Nintendo yeah
entertainment system and you'll also see
if you have the new editions physically
when you actually open the console we've
got the addition of DC stick this new
stick just a direct and on the the back
side we've got the ZL and the z2 our
buttons so those buttons and the
functionality of all of those will
basically act like the Circle Pad Pro
would the accessory that you could buy
stuff for games that are Circle Pad Pro
compatible such as Resident Evil
Revelations or Kid Icarus Uprising I'm
given the upcoming Super Smash Brothers
for Nintendo 3ds you'll actually be able
to utilize the C stick for a range of
different features within those games so
the C stick is not actually another
circle pad is slightly different the
circle pad slides out to these sort of
extremities of that little area here but
the c stick it's sort of like a little
laptop knob that you would kind of use
in place of a mouse right that's right
it's very similar to that so when
actually you were actually using you
weren't actually physically move with a
better term it's very sensitive and it
takes the analog input from the
direction of your thumbs I'm go slightly
redesigned the buttons down here so I've
got the home button in the middle ignore
your start and select back over to the
right under the face button
yep that's correct with the whole
console redesign I mean
then a few things that have had to be
moved around to give it the four factor
required for the the new features so
we've got the volume slider which is on
the top left now the game cart card will
now go on the bottom of the front as
well and the stylus position is also
moved so there's been a few little
things that have that's the bottom face
of the middle we can support out yeah
that's right so what else have we got
new with both of the new Nintendo 3ds
consoles they've got the inbuilt NFC
functionality which is the near-field
communication that you may or may not be
familiar with so that will allow us to
actually be able to connect with amiibo
interactive figurines that are releasing
coming up very soon for both normal
Nintendo 3ds consoles
they'll be an accessory that actually
releases where you'll be able to connect
with the the amiibo using very mature
functionality cool why don't we bring
the young old 3d s in 3d s XL over here
and do a bit of a comparison okay yeah
no worries so my thing with the 3ds and
the 3dsxl the normal 3d s was too
cramped and too small and it's sort of a
farm didn't feel that great to play the
3dsxl much better but for me it's all
produced with a hands trained because
we're just so heavy mm-hmm so how did
has the the new 3d s and the new 3dsxl
compare in terms of both size and weight
the other one in terms of the form
factor for both of these the Union Tendo
3ds XL this one here is a little bit
slimmer than the original Nintendo 3ds
XL but the actual screen size remains
consistent between between the two of
them moving on to Nintendo 3ds is
actually been an increase in the screen
size of Nintendo 3ds up from the
original so right personally idea it
seems to be significant in terms of the
viewing down size of it by time it'll be
up to each of their own to decide when
they get their hands on it so what kind
of a weight difference have we got on
the new 3dsxl compared to the old 3ds
we're looking at the larger consoles the
new Nintendo 3ds XL is actually a little
bit lighter and a little bit slimmer
than the
Nintendo 3ds XL so you will notice that
difference when you pick it up moving on
to the new Nintendo 3ds given that it
has the larger screens it's actually
going to be a little bit heavier and a
little bit wider than the original
Nintendo 3ds but still nice and portable
at the same time yeah yeah it still has
a different form factor as well it's a
lot more curved um a lot I guess you'd
always say softer than the old 3d yes
and you find that with the various
cuddle plates as well I mean some of
them had like uh a kind of a wood finish
as well so it's going to be going to be
able to customize the texture of
actually the console in your hands okay
so with the 3d S the new 3ds XL we we
don't have the cover plates on this yeah
that's exactly right so I mean the new
Nintendo 3ds XL will be launching in
both metallic black and metallic blue
and they have a real kind of luxury look
together with the larger screens and
that's the that's how they those
particular consoles have been designed
so we actually have a different kind of
new approach the actual 3d effect as
well with the 3ds and the 3dsxl you have
to sort of hold them in a very specific
position at a specific distance away
from your eyes to actually keep that 3d
effect and not have it sort of break
apart what are we doing with these are
the new 3d asses yessuh both the new
Nintendo 3ds consoles have what we're
calling super stable 3d and that's a
function within the console that
actually adjusts the 3d to the position
of where your your head is in relation
to the console so using the information
provided from an infrared sensor and
also that the gyro sensor inside yeah as
you if you move the console while
actually playing the game it'll adjust
where that sweet spot is as you as you
move in relation to the console so this
front facing camera is constantly
tracking where your head is
yeah even binds that with the gyro
sensor mm-hmm and so if you if you are
playing you know quite vigorously and
you do happen to move the console a
little bit you'll be able to still see
3d comfortably and so we've also got a
better processor in here as well and
that's going to allow for a few new 3ds
exclusive games all right yeah so right
now we've confirmed in Australia and New
Zealand
that Xenoblade Chronicles will be
available some start sometime in 2015
for new Nintendo 3ds consoles both the
consoles have increased in CPU power and
really what that's going to help us do
is it's going to allow the console to
run more comfortably as well so
switching between software or download
speeds will actually be increased but at
the same time it allows us to run
software that perhaps the Nintendo 3ds
consoles weren't able to win out to run
but existing 3d s games aren't going to
run faster right yeah that's correct I
mean the games in terms of the graphical
output and existing 3d s games will run
comfortably as they always have other
than that we've got the auto brightness
functionality as well yeah it'll
actually you can turn that on or off and
that will adjust the auto brightness
it's a nice little feature and I'm sure
consumers will enjoy finding a lot of
other bits and pieces on the consoles so
out of all these which is your favorite
one you've got these 3d s's with the
faceplates
you've got these metallic silver
metallic blue metallic black sorry
metallic black metallic blue metallic
blue right which ones that which one's
for you look it's a time for me to
decide of them and I love the cover
plates and I also really appreciate
their that the increase in the screen
size on the new Nintendo 3ds as well
comfort is still very affordable and I
can't go past the luxury look of Union
tena 3dsxl so I'm going to say on the
fence down and I'll live it a few to
make up you moon good stuff I like this
one purely because the snares buttons so
yeah that's for me for more of the new
Nintendo 3ds check out games for calm